I remember being like a child and
thinking like 20/20 seemed like a year
that was like oh that's Brett that's
flying harvest mama that space alien and
now that we're here nothing's really
change my iPhone lives a little longer
yeah that's why we have a worse
political like situation yeah the the
horror of living to see the future is
that you realize all those things do
come true but the reality of them is
this they're less shiny and more
horrible you mean your phone you can
share your location
yeah now your ex knows where to come to
you right yeah stalking people is easier
sure I can go hologram but I'm still
feeling just as lonely I like to stalk
people to you I have been off Facebook
probably for two years cuz Facebook in
my opinion
dead sorry Mark Zuckerberg I saw him in
a fight recently he was not hot in
person he was not hot in digital land
either you're right I don't like the
ease with which you can stalk people
I've missed the old days we had a drive
around their you know their house salt a
few times a night stakeouts hello hey
guys yeah hi I'm looking for oh I'm
sorry in the wrong house yeah yeah that
kind of what about the theater of you
know like up the tree binoculars get a
continent in the in the vines that oh
yeah I want the person there's the
comedy and then you fall out of the tree
exactly I want to be up there for like
every night of the week so I bring a
thermos I bring some new magazines and
like I just you know it's not as strong
[Music]